was fühlen sie denn eigentlich bei dem
wort heimat ist es ja irgendwie ein
zuhause ein warmes ein wohliges gefühl
eine zugehörigkeit unsere heimat dieses
wunderschön und hier sind wir auch schon
ein paar bilder schloss neuschwanstein
zum beispiel die ostfriesische küste und
wundervolle berg sehen hören mit diesen
bildern verbinden viele menschen ihrer
heimat und eben rundum positives doch
unsere in ministerin von der spd nancy
faeser sieht das offenbar anders für sie
ist das wort offenbar ein problemfall
sie findet der begriff heimat müsse nun
endlich mal positiv umgedeutet werden
das hat sie auch auf twitter
veröffentlicht riesen kontroverse
übrigens dort jetzt in den sozialen
medien da schreibt sie auf twitter wir
müssen den begriff heimat positiv
umdeuten und so definieren dass er offen
und vielfältig ist und dass er ausdrückt
des menschen selbst entscheiden können
wie sie leben glauben und leben wollen
das wäre ein gewinn für den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt schreibt
sie also ich dachte der begriff heimat
wäre es genau solches dafür dass
zumindest ich bin auch sehr überrascht
darf auf jeden fall bei diesem thema wir
sprechen jetzt mit volker ullrich csu
abgeordneter im bundestag schön dass sie
bei uns sind herr ulrich innenministerin
fekter will also den heimatbegriff
positiv umdeuten meiner heimat
beispielsweise ist bayern was ist daran
den negativ
also darin ist gar nichts negativ mich
hat die einlassung unserer
bundesministerin sehr irritiert zum
einen weil sie einen begriff
staatlicherseits definieren möchte aber
ist entscheiden die menschen wie sie den
heimatbegriff das ist keine staatliche
aufgabe und dann steuerlich sehr daran
dass der begriff heimat nicht positiv
sein soll ganz im gegenteil viele viele
menschen unserem garten verbinden mit
heimat etwas schönes ein gefühl ein
zuhause die herkunft das ist offen für
alle ist ein begriff der bereits jetzt
schön ist und der nicht staatlicherseits
umdefiniert sein muss und man fragt sich
an dieser stelle natürlich auch wie
kommt sie denn überhaupt darauf dass es
nichts positives sein könnte und wie
will sie das überhaupt umsetzen
ja das verstehe ich selbst nicht mich
hat dieser tweet
die ministerin sehr irritiert sie stößt
damit viele menschen vor den kopf die
heime das etwas positives empfinden und
der heimatbegriff bei uns ist der nicht
ausschließen sondern er bindet die
menschen eigen egal woher sie kommen es
ist ein gefühl das jeder in unserem land
teilen kann und bei dem viele menschen
ein wohliges gefühl haben wenn sie an
ihre eigene heimat denken manchmal wird
der begriff heimat ja auch negativ
genutzt beispielsweise von der afg von
rechtsextremen sollte man dem irgendwie
einheit gebieten in zwar mit diesem
vorschlag dass man den begriff neu
definiert oder wie kann man da
entgegenwirken
ja das ist ein allgemeines phänomen dass
rechtsextremisten versuchen positiv
besetzte begriffe für sich selbst
umzubringen und diese begriffe zu
verwenden
wir müssen darauf eine ganz klare
gesellschaftliche antwort geben die mit
diese positive begriffe nicht den
rechtsextremisten überlassen sondern
ihnen widersprechen die wir deutlich
machen dass deren heimatbegriff dass
deren art und weise zu leben und zu
denken nicht von der großen mehr unser
land geteilt wird sondern dass respekt
und toleranz zu unserem heimatbegriff
dazu gehört und dass wir die
rechtsextremen rechts liegen lassen sagt
volker ullrich besten dank für ihre
einschätzung und grüße in ihrer heimat
danke sehr